[Music]  you  one of my favorite things is to  demystify these olds traditional types  of clothing like the double-breasted  suit it is really the kingpin of your  fall wardrobe  once you're buttoned up it makes you  look slimmer and trimmer it's like your  coat of armor in a way  it's one of those suits that I think a  lot of guys pay stereotypic I put it in  a box but it really does have a new  modern look to it a double-breasted suit  is always going to get you noticed at  the office it is definitely going to be  a head turner suit start it off on  Monday with a white shirt and a gray  wooly tie by Thursday when you're into  the casual part of the week put it with  a beautiful polo shirt or put it with a  turtleneck at this point I would say  every guy should run out and get one  you  [Music]